hi everyone its Jonah here and one of
the most common question that people
asks when they want to lose weight or to
put our weight or even to maintain their
weight is how much calories should they
eat or should they burn in a day and in
this video I really want to get down to
the details for you to understand how
much calories you need to consume and
why before we start I want you to be as
truthful as you can in regards to your
measurements in order for us to see
result and for this process to work
there is no secret to losing weight if
you want to lose weight the calories you
burned need to be greater than the
calories you consume and if one put on
weight is vice versa calories comes from
your fat carbs protein and alcohol I've
got my laptop here so if you can grab a
piece of paper grab a pen and grab a
calculator because we'll be doing some
mathematics I've broken the process down
into five steps which is what I also
call 5/8 the first a is called
attainable goes what you need to do
before you want to start losing weight
is to set yourself an attainable goal so
ask yourself two questions how much do
you want to lose and by when make sure
they are realistic and just so you know
in order to lose one pound of fat you
need to burn 3,500 calories so if your
goal is to lose five pound of fat that's
seventeen thousand five hundred calories
the safe and recommended way to lose
weight is to lose not more than one to
two pounds a week and that is safe and
sustainable if you were to lose weight
quick the chances are you will put on
weight quickly as well so have you
written down how much you want to lose
and by web okay remember that and take
note of that and the second a is called
aware be aware I understand your basic
metabolic rate your BM are by
understanding your basal metabolic rate
you
know how much calories do you need to
consume a day in order to keep your body
moving your BMR is how much your body
burns in a day without you doing
anything so that's really you know to
keep your heart pumping to keep your
brain going basically to just keep your
whole body moving that's your BMR so get
your calculator ready as you'll be
finding out what your BMR is there are
two formulas to this the first one is
called the English BMR formula where we
uses pounds and inches all the metrics
BMR formula using centimeters and kilos
you can use whichever formula that suits
you so there are four factors in
calculating your BMR your gender weight
height and your age I'll be using the
English upm our formula so grab your pen
and write this down for a woman in order
to calculate your BMR what you need to
do is take six hundred fifty five plus
four point three five times your weight
in pounds plus four point seven times
your height in inches minus four point
seven times your age in years and if
you're a man this is how you calculate
your BMR take sixty six plus six point
two three times your weight in pounds
plus twelve point seven times your
height in inches minus six point eight
times your age in years that's the
English BMR formula so for example if I
were to take if I were to calculate my
BMR I will be taking six hundred fifty
five plus four point three five times
one hundred and ten pounds because
that's my weight plus four point seven
times five foot three that's my height
minus four point seven times 24 that's
my age in years and so my BMR is one
three one six
point eight calories remember this is
just an estimation what it's telling me
is that my body burns 1316 calories
without me doing anything and therefore
if I were to consume this amount of
calories without doing anything I would
not put on weight if I were to consume
less I will lose weight and if I were to
consume more I will put on weight okay
so that's a second a another third a is
activity level this is very important to
know how much calories you need to
consume because obviously we don't just
lie in there and do nothing so what you
need to do is take your BMR and multiply
it with your activity level so if you're
the kind of person that has very little
exercise or no exercise at all your
activity level is 1.2 if you're lightly
active when you workout one to three
times per week your activity level is
one point three seven five if you are
moderately active when you workout three
to five times a week then your activity
level is one point five five and if
you're very active where you work out
six to seven times a week then your
activity level is one point seven to
five and if you're extra active your
activity level is 1.9 and if you're
extra active trust me you don't need
this because there's no way you're
putting on weight and so take note of
that what you need to do now is to take
your BMR and multiply it with the
activity level
so my BMR is 1 3 1 6 point 8 multiplied
by 1 point 5 5 and that gives me 2041
calories so if I were to workout three
to five times a week in a day I can
consume 2041 calories to maintain my
weight if I were to consume more than
2041 calories that's when I'll start
putting on weight and if I were to
consume less that's when I'll start
losing weight okay so now you know your
BMR and you know your activity
well you know how much calories you need
to consume to maintain your weight the
fall a is application this is a time for
us to apply everything in order for you
to achieve your goal the first
application is to calculate how much
calories should you eat if you want to
lose weight and remember this is just an
estimation there are many other factors
to consider but let's start with the
ground basic rules I'm going to take a
case study to give you an example of how
to calculate and apply this I have got a
client with a female and she's 28 years
old her height is 165 centimeters she
weighs 75 kilos and her goal is to lose
5 kilos before summer time so that's
about 8 weeks and she just started
working out so I would consider her
activity level as lightly active so
let's start by calculating her BMR and
you can do this by calculating your own
VM or as well and that gives me her BMR
of 1540 calories without having her to
do anything
remember the heavier you are the more
your body burns the lighter you are the
less your body burns now what we'll need
to calculate and what you'll need to
calculate is how much your body needs in
order to maintain your weight if you
were to workout one to three times a
week so 1540 multiplied by one point
three seven five because I'm considering
her to be lightly active and that gives
me 2118 calories in order for her to
maintain overweight that's how much she
can consume to maintain her weight but
that's not a goal her goal is to lose
weight what she wants to lose is five
kilos which equals 211 pounds that also
equals to 38 thousand five hundred
calories that she needs to burn it's not
possible to were in a day and it's not
possible to burn in a week but it's
realistic for her to lose it in eight
weeks so now what I'll need to calculate
is how much calories
does she need to burn in a week so
38,500 calories divided by eight weeks
that gives me four thousand eight
hundred and twelve calories for her to
save or burn per week and how much
calories does she need to burn a day
let's divide that again by seven she
will need to save about six hundred
eighty seven point five calories per day
there are two ways to save your calories
or to burn your calories the first way
is to make sure that you're eating 687
calories less or whatever calories that
you need to save the second way is
through exercise I would recommend to do
both when you combine both that's when
you see quicker results and that's when
you will be able to maintain your weight
because the key to remember is that the
more muscles your body put on the higher
your metabolism goes up and the more fat
you burn in a day and muscles can only
begin through working out not through
dieting or not through your eating
habits coming back to my case study for
her to lose 11 pounds in eight weeks
she should be consuming about 1430
calories per day and nothing more so how
can she do this first is to watch a diet
by not consuming more than that and the
second option is to work out so for
example if she were to work out for
three days on the day that she is not
working out on or on the day that you're
not working out try not to consume more
than 1430 calories or whatever calories
that you need to consume in order for
you to lose weight and on the day where
you are working on or on the day where
she is working out she can consume
slightly more and you can consume
slightly more as well for example if you
were to build an average of 300 to 400
calories
in a workout add that 300 calories to
your daily calories requirement so if
she only needs 1430 calories to lose
weight on the day that she is working
out she can add 300 calories more
because when you're working out your
body is using up much more energy and
you need food to bill your muscles so
consume 300 calories more but do not
over consume because what happens is
when people start working out they start
eating more and they do not see reason
and the wonder why I'm working out and
I'm not seeing result why well let me
tell you why because you're eating more
than what you should be eating that's
how much calories you need to eat in a
day and when you're working out try to
burn at least 300 calories whatever you
do remember that the minimum requirement
keep your body going is nothing less
than 1200 calories do not consume
anything less than 1200 calories you
would damage your body and also don't
forget that your drinks carry calories
as well so make sure you count that in
to your diet or your eating habit last
but not least the fifth a and my last a
which is very important the most
important here is your attitude if you
want to lose weight you got to make a
start you got to make that conscious
decision that my goal is to lose 10
pounds for example in eight weeks time
or my goal is to lose 20 pounds in you
know chopped weeks time start taking
action and change your mindset remember
that when you're just starting off do
not give up it takes time it takes time
for you to put on weight it takes time
for you to lose weight as well so really
make your journey a fun one have a
positive attitude don't just work out
for the sake of working out don't go on
a diet for the sake of going on a diet
really enjoy the journey and joy
the food you're eating enjoy your
workout and really always remember your
goal in order to achieve it so change
your mindset change the way you look at
yourself you've got to start loving
yourself first before you can make any
changes persistent is a key do not give
up do not ever give up people that see
results are those people that never give
up and don't be too obsessed about your
weight or calories count remember this
is just an indication for you to start
off with but most importantly you need
to enjoy the entire process so do have a
positive attitude I know we can do it
let me know how you get on and if you do
have any questions just leave your
comments and I'll answer them don't
forget to subscribe to my channel for
more nutritional and fitness tips make
sure you enjoy the process